[Music]
claire bronfman was born into one of the
most prominent families in modern
history
she had the means to live any way she
wanted anywhere she wanted
but of all the paths she could have
taken she took the path that led to her
serving time in federal prison for her
leadership role
in nexium
[Music]
this is how claire and her sister sarah
poured more than 100 million dollars
into one of the most notorious cults of
the 21st century
edgar bronfman senior was the son of
samuel bronfman
a russian immigrant who built sigrums
into one of the largest distillers in
the world
and got rich during prohibition claire
and sarah were the two youngest children
of the late billionaire edgar bronfman
senior
edgar senior and their mother rita
georgiana webb
divorced for the second time in the
1990s and the girls spent most of their
time
living with their mother in the english
countryside
claire was introverted and never
finished high school instead
training as a competitive show jumper
her sister sara describes her as
being sweet caring a little clumsy and
incredibly sensitive claire and her
sister sarah grew up on a farm with
their mother
but when they turned 18 a trust fund was
waiting for each
sarah says we were not raised to be
heiresses
nor did we understand we would be we
grew up in another world
we were just like everyone else but then
we weren't
unbeknownst to us we had millions of
dollars awaiting us
on our 18th birthdays
in the beginning nexium was offering
executive coaching classes
and appeared to be like other innocuous
self-help groups
edgar senior took a course and thought
it could benefit both claire and sarah
who were struggling to find a purpose in
their life
they too enrolled to the delight of
keith renery
but edgar's enthusiasm waned and became
suspicious of reneri's intentions after
realizing that claire loaned her leader
two million dollars
it kind of opened up his eyes through
this
loan he realized like oh my god my
daughters
might be targeted uh because of their
immense wealth
in 2003 we put keith renery who's the
leader of
nexium on the cover of forbes and the
blockbuster quote
from that piece is edgar bronfman saying
i think it's a cult
what this article looked into was the
more
strange and concerning behaviors of
keith and
certain members of the group the curtain
was drawn back it was like this guy is
not the smartest man in the world this
group has manipulative
tendencies and even its course work
is really concerning so this article
really put
nexium's darker tendencies on the map
and um it really put nexium's story
in the mainstream media
the fallout for the story was really
unclear and it indebted her
to keith for their whole relationship it
was this turning point where he
finally had something over her she like
owed it to him to try to fix it but you
know obviously it could never be fixed
because the damage was done
keith made claire believe that her
father had it
out for him and that he wanted to
destroy
nexium and that edgar was part of the
illuminati
you know like really crazy paranoid
things while edgar senior publicly and
privately voiced his suspicions
claire found a purpose and community
within nexium and refused to part ways
with the group
after the forbes article was published
claire had spyware installed onto her
father's computer to monitor him
according to witness testimony according
to claire's lawyer
her and her father made up and she
helped take care of him at the end of
his life
i think it's easy for us to look at
these people who um you know are in news
stories
being in a cult like how could that ever
happen like
they must be stupid and their eyes must
be closed
you know cults don't advertise like hey
join us it's [ __ ] nuts over here like
we do insane
things and it's dangerous and scary it's
just a group of like-minded people who
want to get along and chat
after time goes on you realize they cut
you off from the world
or you know tell you you know it's not
the best to tell your friends what we do
here
and then eventually that alienation
starts and
um the closest people to you in your
life are are people in this group and
then
it's too late or it's really hard to to
separate because you know you do
grow fondness for people that you spend
time with so i think that
to me that was the most interesting
aspect that it's
not hard
rick ross a cult d programmer and
founder of the cult education institute
defended himself against a 14-year long
lawsuit waged by keith renery
and offers his perspective on the group
nexium targeted celebrities targeted the
wealthy
and these people were conned keith
renery would have
imploded a long time before
he did if it wasn't for the fact that
claire bronfman was his bank
she and her sister sarah were feeding
him millions and millions and millions
of dollars
including paying for all of his
litigation there was this incredible
sucking sound coming
out of their bank because the money was
being
vacuumed into keith renery's coffers to
pay for all of his lawyers
another thing he did that was really
interesting psychologically speaking
was seagram's is a canadian company and
when the u.s prohibited alcohol
seagram's put whiskey distilleries on
the border of
u.s and canada and their whiskey was fed
right into the black market
how keith spun their fortune was like
your fortune
is dirty your fortune is evil it came
from crime like all this
all this crazy stuff he said like claire
you need
to clean this money and you can clean it
through nexium because we're a noble
ethical
organization and claire bought into that
claire gave more than 100 million
dollars to nexium over 15 years
a major chunk of her money went towards
suing nexium's enemies
both real and perceived to smithereens
sarah eventually left the group got
married and moved away
she was never charged with any crimes
but claire
remained a devoted member over 15 years
it's estimated that claire hired 50 to
60 lawyers to pursue cases against
nearly a dozen nexium critics
at least three people who defended
themselves against nexium's aggressive
legal strategy
eventually filed for personal bankruptcy
protection
[Music]
barbara boucher joined nexium in 2001
and was one of its earliest executive
board members
she dated keith for many years she also
owned a successful financial planning
company becoming claire and sarah's
financial advisor
and managed a small portion of their
wealth bouche was the first person to
sound the alarm on the unethical
practices within the group
and eventually left the group after her
departure
keith went after her in both civil and
criminal court over the duration of the
next eight years
14 litigations four states eight judges
there were thousands of court filings
and barbara spent almost a million
dollars defending herself
ultimately all charges against barbara
were dropped
it's been 20 years of my life and it's
taken a toll on my body and my nervous
system and i
still have a lot of post-traumatic
stress
keith used claire's money as a reign of
terror
within the organization if it were not
for claire brothman
he would have never been able to have
done any of that and probably would have
been brought down a hell of a lot sooner
than he was so claire is very
responsible she played a key role
the tipping point was the day the new
york times published their article about
dos
a secretive group within nexium federal
investigators then arrested keith neary
on charges of racketeering
sex trafficking conspiracy forced labor
identity theft sexual exploitation of a
child
and possession of child pornography a
few months later
claire bronfman was indicted and charged
with a racketeering conspiracy
including identity theft extortion
forced labor
sex trafficking money laundering wire
fraud
and obstruction of justice bronfman made
a deal with prosecutors and only pled
guilty to identity theft
and immigration fraud and was sentenced
to 81 months in prison
ranieri was convicted on all charges and
will spend the rest of his life
in prison probably one of the saddest
things that
came about through the trial was this
email exchange between claire and her
father
edgar writes whether or not you want to
believe me i do not lie
and i love you too very much someone is
not telling you the truth
why don't you try and figure out who
that might be
who has something to gain certainly not
me
what would be my motive and then he
signs off
tons of love even if not requited pops
keith saw a rift in a family dynamic
and he exploited it for his own personal
gain
she justified it for the greater good
and that
is the crime because
keith can influence her all he wants
people can say
she was brainwashed and unduly
influenced and i beg to differ
it's claire who chooses to pick up that
sword
and that's why she's a criminal she knew
it was wrong
and she did it anyway i really do think
that there is goodness in her
i've seen it i know it and i believe
that she
in the end wants to do right and wants
to be a humanitarian
she is a woman with wealth power as a
means
to fix the wrongs which most people
would never have
that kind of ability to do so
she could turn this around and become
you know quite the story down the road
[Music]
you